Salut à tous ! Une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours.
D'abord je vous donne la solution d'hier, et ensuite l'énigme du jour.
Solution d'hier. Attention si vous n'avez pas regardé la vidéo d'hier, allez voir l'énigme avant.
La réponse est 24862.
Je vous laisse vérifier en regardant la vidéo d'hier. Toutes les prémices sont bonnes.
La seule solution possible c'est 24862.
Ne nous attardons pas et passons à l'énigme d'aujourd'hui !
Enigme numéro 23 ! C'est l'énigme de...?
L'escargot. C'est un escargot que j'ai essayé de vous faire, c'était pathétique ! [rires]
C'est l'histoire d'un escargot qui veut grimper au sommet d'un mur de 10 mètres.
Mais il se déplace très bizarrement notre escargot.
La journée il arrive à monter 3 mètres, mais durant la nuit, avec le froid et l'humidité, il redescend de 2 mètres.
En partant du principe qu'il va commencer à grimper le mur de tout en bas, un matin, combien de jours il lui faudra pour atteindre le sommet du mur, donc les 10 mètres ?
Vous pouvez soit mettre ça sur une feuille de papier pour essayer de trouver plus facilement, ou alors dresser un escargot !
C'est possible.
Mais c'est long pour la réponse...
Sachant que je la donnerai de toute manière demain à 11H.
Et vous, dès que vous avez trouvé, n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en l'air pour qu'on sache le nombre de personnes
qui ont réussi à résoudre cette énigme ou alors, qui la connaissaient peut-être.
Et dans les vidéos, il n'y a pas besoin de parcourir 10 mètres pour trouver le bouton pour s'abonner.
Il y a sur le logo ici,
ou juste sous la vidéo.
Donc pensez à vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H. Dimanche matin, c'est 11H.
Ciao !